Mình một tháng bầy, toán ninh giăng thẩn thả nội tuyên phát ốc quyển văn hộ, chưa tịch tập đòàn fút xân,
3,5.8.2.0, đưa hối lộ, mười bụ năm, vì phạm quy định việc kế toán, bị năm,
và vì phạm quy định video thồ chiến 1.0.
Ô hậu bị cáo bột chi một chăm 3.2 tỳ đau và hàng triệu đô làm bị hối lộ như cụ let đạo tình vĩnh phút quang ngái,
để thâu to mười bụn đội thậu, gây thiệt hại hơn một bịt một trăm sóm mới tỳ đồng chân ngắn nước.
Tòa cũng tuyến án nhiều vị cầu khác là cử lệnh đạo cán bộ phúc sơn và chính quyền địa phương liên quan với mất an từ 2 năm tục đến sản năng tục.
Dương ông đạo Trung Hoàng cử chẳng quan phòng viện bị mang thiết, bị tuyến 3 mới tháng tục.
Vi lợi dụng anh hưởng để trục lợi tám trong mời trợ đồng.
Trong có trình sế sử, đặc đàn thúc sơn đã nộ bộ xung bầy chăm sau mới tám tỷ đồng,
con khoảng tiên ông hậu đã hấp phục trước đó đủ đủ đặc quan bộ thiệt hạ buwan, ông hậu yếu lên bay tò hối hình và xin giám lệ hình phát cho các vị cầu liên đối.